and talking about that we're learning
more about the victims killed here in El
Paso they include a high school student
an Army veteran and a mom who died
protecting her baby Janet shamlian is
also here in El Paso with some of their
stories and Janet just outside the
memorial what have we learned
Nora good morning El Paso ins want to
help they want to do something and this
morning they've set up this memorial on
the perimeter of this Wal Mart
we are as you said learning more about
their stories they spoke different
languages they were from different
countries but the stories we're hearing
are about what they had in common a love
of family and in some cases putting
themselves in harm's way to save the
life of a loved one
this was El Paso Sunday night hundreds
sharing collective grief including El
Paso congresswoman Veronica Escobar I
never imagined this would happen here
but when you use the power of words to
divide people when you use it to make
one group hate another group there is
going to be violence mourners celebrated
lives gone too soon
fifteen-year-old Javier Amy Rodriguez
played soccer and would have gone back
to school in a few weeks
multiple Mexican nationals were killed
so was 86 year old Angie Angliss be who
spoke to her son on the phone just
minutes before the shooting 60 year-old
Army veteran Arturo Nino Benavides died
while paying at the register as his wife
waited outside Jordan and Andre on
chotto had just celebrated their
one-year wedding anniversary family
members say the 25 year old mom of three
appears to have died shielding and
ultimately saving their two month-old
son he's got two broken fingers a couple
of bruises but he's alive obviously from
the her heroics of both his mother and
his father that made the ultimate
sacrifice as any parent I'm sure would
Maribel lakhtin was fundraising with her
daughter's soccer team outside Walmart
when the gunman opened fire
he shot a more rounds and all I could
is God please take care of my children
she was shot twice later finding her
daughter and the other girls safe after
bakery workers hid them inside children
their ages no children in any world
should see things like that they
shouldn't and they shouldn't there are
random acts of kindness in every
direction here Blood Center is so
overwhelmed they ask people to stop
coming and at the hospital
visitors showing up hour after hour with
food for toys with families for families
of the victims and those are people they
did not even know Janet thank you I have
seen that hashtag El Paso strong our
coverage from El Paso will continue
ahead here on CBS this morning and I'll
send it back to you guys in New York I
think one of the stories we are going to
be following today is this extraordinary
warning that came very late last night
from the director of the FBI talking
about warning that violent extremists
could be inspired by what happened here
and also him revealing for the first
time that in just the spring of this
year they have set up a new unit within
the FBI to deal with these extremists
directly this is the threat that we are
facing today yeah that's right now a
very unusual warning from though from
the FBI